(casting)
What’s up guys, I’m Colin McNeil for theScore
esports and that was kenny-f--king-S.
I could tell you that he’s one of the best
to ever play the game of Counter-Strike.
I could tell you he's in the discussion for top AWPers, ever.
But I probably don’t have to, because if you know CS, you know Kenny,
and you know his playstyle.
And if you don't, well, you're in for a treat.
Sit back, hit the subscribe button, and get ready.
This is the Best
of kennyS.
(casting)
Okay, so one of the first things you need to know about
kennyS is that he could be described as prodigy.
He started his professional CS:GO
at 15-years old, in Counter-Strike: Source.
At the time, he played on one of the very best Source teams around, VeryGames.
(casting)
Now look, in esports terms, all that Source stuff, pretty much ancient history.
These days he plays on French superteam
G2 Esports.
And through AWP nerfs, roster changes, and everything else, he remains the AWP god we all know him to be.
(casting)
But look, it’s not just about the AWP.
A player like kennyS can thrive on just about any weapon.
Just take a look at this.
(casting)
Okay so he plays like a machine, but you have to understand
that kennyS' success ebbs and flows with his emotions.
If he’s feeling himself on a given day, get out of the server, straight up.
If not, well...
(casting)
Goddamn. kennyS really is one of the best.
Now that's all we've for you on this weeks episode of Best of.
Let me know in the comments below who we should cover next week, and I'll see you then.